To access Udacity,
we first need to log into Udacity
using our Georgia Tech credentials.
So first go to udacity.com and
then click to sign in at the top.
Since we're Georgia Tech students,
we'll click Sign in with
Georgia Tech at the bottom.
Here you'll enter your
Georgia Tech ID and your password.
Once you log in,
you'll see a My Courses tab at the top.
If you click the drop-down,
you'll see a list of classes that
you currently have access to.
>> Note that udacity.com changes with
some regularity, so make sure to check
out the instructor notes below this
video for any information on whether or
not anything you've seen
in this video has changed.
But now we'll move onto talking
about the main pages of
the classes you'll take.